[Musique]
hatem nafti bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france
il y a dix ans jour pour jour ben ali
quittait le pouvoir aujourd'hui
plusieurs événements sont organisés un
peu partout en tunisie pour autant est
ce que les tunisiens vont célébrer cette
date anniversaire alors je pense qu' il
n'y aura aucun événement aujourd'hui
pour une raison très simple c'est qu'on
a instauré en confinement de quatre
jours qui démarre aujourd'hui et qui qui
s'achève dimanche
donc a priori ça devrait être observée
parce que la situation est de plus en
plus incontrôlable autant la première
vague a été particulièrement clémente
autant là on compte autour de 60 70
morts par jour donc il ya un confinement
qui a été décrétée aujourd'hui et qui
court jusqu'à dimanche
mais évidemment il ça peut être contesté
mais a priori devrait pas y avoir de
grands rassemblements en tout cas les
grandes organisations n'ont pas
s'associer à quelque chose qui fera
frais le confinement pour autant dix ans
après qu'est ce qui reste de deux
départs de ben ali aujourd'hui chez les
tunisiens alors ce qui reste est ce que
si vous parlez avec le tunisien du
quotidien il va vous expliquer que ce
qu'on a eu jusqu'ici c'est la liberté
d'expression là c'est un acquis claire
considérable qui absolument pas
comparable fin qui est sans commune
mesure avec ce qu'on peut avoir dans les
autres pays arabes
donc ça effectivement on peut parler on
peut critiquer il n'y a pas deux y'a pas
de problème pour le reste il ya une
démocratie qu'est en train de se mettre
en place mais l'économie ne suis pas la
crise sanitaire n'a fait qu'aggraver une
situation qui était déjà explosive
donc les gens voient au mieux leur
niveau de vie stagne et au pire ils se
voient d'éclat c est ce qui explique que
chez une partie de plus en plus
importante en plébiscite un retour à un
régime dictatorial en tout cas un régime
beaucoup plus autoritaire et ça veut
dire que certains regrettent l'ère ben
ali finalement aujourd'hui
tout à fait tout à fait si vous prenez
les sondages par exemple pour les
législatives le parti qui arrive
largement en tête c'est le parti des
citoyens libres qui est si vous voulez
la continuité de l'ancien régime qui se
revendiquent de l'ancien régime et qui
ne crois absolument pas à 7 à cette
révolution
en contrepartie ans continuent à
plébisciter le président de la
république donc c'est un petit peu le en
même temps tunisiens ont continuent à
plébisciter le président de la
république qui lui s'inscrit clairement
dans dance est dans cette révolution est
donc voilà les tunisiens sont dans cet
entre deux on regrette mais on continue
pour l'instant en tout cas à faire
confiance à la révolution mais on n'est
pas contre suivre quelqu'un qui nous
promet un meilleur avenir quitte à ce
que ce soit aux dépens des des droits et
des libertés fondamentales de la
démocratie alors colère ou amer on l'a
entendu pour autant ces années est-ce
qu'elle marque une vraie démocratisation
de la tunisie
en tout cas le système politique et de
tout cas clairement démocratique il ya
des élections qui son livre il y à t
enfin tout le monde ou presque peut se
peut se présenter il n'ya pas les seins
sûr qu'on voit dans les autres pays il
ya des institutions qui sont en train de
se mettre en place
même si elle peine à se mettre en place
et beaucoup de retard notamment dans les
institutions fondées par là par la
deuxième république notamment la cour
constitutionnelle qui est un petit peu
le la pierre angulaire de cette
architecture qui n'est toujours pas en
place
mais effectivement il ya des élections
il ya des élections libres
est ce qu'elles sont satisfaisantes jeu
mal le disons le système électoral de
plus en plus décrié
les majorités sont pas stables dont il
ya une démocratie si vous voulez pour
résumer il ya une démocratie mais une
démocratie qui est quand même assez
fragile et qui permettent pas de
gouverner durablement impayés donc de
changer ce qui explique aussi la crise
économique c'est que en moyenne un
gouvernement reste au pouvoir
un an au tour d'un an c'est très varié
u9 en dix ans il ya eu neuf gouvernement
et donc à partir de là on comprend qu'il
n'y ait pas eu de réforme qui est pas eu
de changement sur la partie économique
et social une situation économique
également catastrophiques
tout le secteur du tourisme qui est
complètement à l'arrêt oui alors
vraiment le secteur du tourisme qui qui
est un des secteurs clés de l'économie
tunisienne depuis depuis l'indépendance
a été touché par des vagues successives
à des crises successives il ya eu un
premier reflux après la révolution donc
évidemment une instabilité
ça fait fuir les touristes il ya eu
autour de 2000 entre 2014 et 2015
surtout l'année 2015 et une vague
d'attentats qui a touché des touristes
il ya une reprise qui va notamment du
tourisme venant d'algérie qui a été
coupée net par la crise du coc vide les
frontières et la frontière avec
l'algérie temps tout simplement fermé et
donc ça c'est un secteur qui souffre
énormément qui qui génère énormément
d'emplois directs et indirects et qui
reste sur en plus ce qui n'a pas été
réformé qui reste sur du tourisme de
masse du tourisme low cost et donc c'est
un secteur qui est qui endeuillé par une
vague successive de crise alors en
quelques mots la jeunesse tunisienne
était plein d'espoir on souvient
aujourd'hui elle est largement touchés
par le chômage sont les grands perdants
aujourd'hui les jeunes oui tout à fait
les si vous voulez déjà les jeunes ont
fait la révolution c'est ce qui se dit
c'est ce qui se dit partout pour autant
quand vous voyez
les grands décideurs en tunisie s'est
pas vraiment des jeunes on est on est
sur une génération la génération qui
tout pouvoir c'est celle qui a été qui
était militante dans les années 80 dans
les universités vous comprenez dès lors
que bon les jeunes sont très très peu
associé à ça il ya eu des mouvements
jeunes très important notamment en face
à une loi de réconciliation qui allaient
qu'ils allaient totalement étouffé le
processus de justice transitionnelle
mais les jeunes sont globalement
convoyer la classe politique les jeunes
sont faction bon à distribuer des tracts
mais ils sont très très peu associés à
la gestion à la gestion du pays et ce
qui explique le désarroi ambiant
merci beaucoup à thème nafti d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin dans la
matinale verte et france rappelle que
vous êtes essayiste et auteur de tunisie
dessine-moi une révolution aux éditions
de l'harmattan